[Music]
the Northwest Territories state of
emergency this Wednesday night the
community is reduced to rubble and
growing fears as flames creep closer to
the capital
igniting legal action
the lawsuits blaming Hawaii's power
provider for the deadly and disastrous
wildfires has the highway to Lahaina
reopens
Canada's housing market cools down
what's putting the Chill on sales and
construction
and a brain scan of a different kind how
artificial intelligence could read your
mind
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight para Nasser good
evening to you thanks so much for
joining us we begin with what is now a
state of emergency in the Northwest
Territories the situation dire the area
vast and tonight we're getting a
startling look at what the fire has left
in its wake
a post-apocalyptic scene in the hamlet
of Enterprise cars burnt down to their
frames as flames quickly scorched a path
through the remote Community this is
just a glimpse of the more than 21
000 square kilometers that have already
burned in the territory an area roughly
four times the size of Pei
and that area will grow as more than 230
wildfires continue to Burn Tonight
concerns are especially growing around
Yellowknife as winds push the Flames
closer to the city of twenty thousand
there is a chance that with the out rain
that this fire could reach the outskirts
of our capital city by the weekend so
we're preparing and we're doing
everything we can to prevent that
eventuality but this is a very serious
situation
we'll have more from our crew on the
ground in Yellowknife in just a moment
but first we go to Heather your ex West
on the fire fight in one of the most
remote parts of Canada as this country's
historic Wildfire season continues to
devastate families
once happy homes and vibrant businesses
reduced to their bones and covered in
Ash I lost quite a bit I lost my house a
couple of shops everything
I've worked for and worked on all my
projects and everything I loved in life
is gone the father of three runs a
plumbing business in the northern Hamlet
of Enterprise a community of 100 people
where nearly every building has been
consumed by Flames the Northwest
Territories has never faced a situation
like this in terms of wildfire the thing
that is making this year much different
is the scale of the human toll of what's
being faced with more than 200 wildfires
burning and thousands already forced
from their homes Yellowknife a city of
twenty thousand people is now under
threat we're dealing with a fire that
has reached with 17 kilometers to the
Northeast Northwest of uh of our capital
city of Yellowknife uh it is a fire that
is uh continued to burn hot and offer
significant challenges to firefighting
efforts with several neighborhoods
already under an evacuation alert some
hospital patients and long-term care
residents have been moved out of the
city for some like the mother of this
Fort Smith evacuee it's the third or
fourth move in less than a week she's 83
years old with severe dementia and
Jenny's 24-hour care in Hay River there
is more positive news light winds
assisted firefighting efforts and
Community officials believe the air
evacuation operation is complete for now
there are more strong winds and high
temperatures in the forecast which means
it could be some time before residents
of the South slave region are allowed to
come home you feel kind of lost
we're just sitting here wondering what's
going to happen next
anxiety running high as the Wildfire
crisis across the Northwest Territories
intensifies Heather York's West Global
News
and as you heard the fire's next Target
is the most populous area of the
territory our Jamie Dahl is in
Yellowknife Jamie what's the mood there
like right now
debilitating smoke has been hanging
heavy overheads for weeks now this
afternoon Yellowknife seeing some blue
sky but it's not diminishing the stress
and the anxiety bearing down on this
Northern City you can feel it you can
see it on people's faces many scrambling
to fill their tanks to put their
belongings in the car just in case
because what they really need is rain
and they're not getting it and that fire
just on the outskirts of the city is
steadily growing is it unnerving
yeah it's a little unnerving yeah some
residents who live outside the city
limits including Wayne Lanigan have
already been told to leave he's been
packing up for three days and he says he
rented one of the last remaining storage
lockers I'm trying to take the most
expensive stuff first and leave the
cheaper stuff to last stressful how do
you get the music extremely right now
it's getting pretty close we're hoping
for a weather change within the next
couple days it'll back it off but right
now it's like everybody got to get out
of here Wildfire breaks are being built
and firefighters are also spilling into
this area this Camp just on the
outskirts of the city hosted 100
firefighters last night some from as far
away as South Africa more ecstatic we're
doing everything we can to help him out
and yeah it's
now the fire is about 17 kilometers
outside the city limits but but fire
officials say if this dry hot weather
persists and the Winds Don't shift it
could be just within five kilometers by
Friday
Farah Jamie doll in Yellowknife thank
you Jamie the aggressive growth of a
wildfire in southern BC has trapped at
least 80 campers and staff in Cathedral
Provincial Park the crater Creek fires
burned about 10 000 hectares and is
affecting the only Road through the park
officials are assessing options to
rescue people by air an evacuation order
is in effect but people are being
advised to shelter in place at the lodge
which is not in danger hot dry weather
has also triggered evacuation orders
west of liluit a ridge of high pressure
is hovering over BC leading to a heat
wave with record-breaking temperatures a
dry cold front is expected to bring
strong winds and lightning on Thursday
turning now to the Grim recovery mission
on Maui where it could take months even
years to identify everyone killed and
that devastating wildfire that raised
Lahaina more than a week ago now
only five of the 106 bodies recovered
have been identified Hawaii's governor
Josh Green says the situation is like
what you see in a war zone or 9 11. he
says the remains that are being found
are unrecognizable and fingerprints are
hard to come by families desperately
waiting to hear about lost loved ones
have been asked to provide swabs and DNA
samples to help identify the victims
more than 1 000 people are still missing
officials warn the death toll will
likely double or grow even further as
Crews sift through the toxic Rubble only
a third of the disaster Zone has been
searched so far arnitha Garcia is in
Maui and nithu you got a firsthand look
at all that's been lost
pharah I'm standing Inside the Fire
ravaged town of Lahaina in a step
towards what Hawaii's governor called an
effort to bring back some kind of
normalcy here a major road connecting
this devastated Community to the rest of
the island of Maui was reopened to the
public this morning
at the crack of dawn Vehicles lined up
by the dozens waiting to take the route
which had been significantly restricted
with police checkpoints blocking access
for most people over the last week
it forced some groups to send in
supplies by boat
from the road above the historic Seaside
Town once the capital of the Kingdom of
Hawaii you can see the trail of
Destruction all the history that went up
in smoke it's been pretty devastating
you run into animals that have been
through the fire uh they're still alive
they're fighting restoration workers
like Kevin keaney have been in the
community preparing to welcome people
back a lot of people don't even know
what happened to their property they
weren't allowed to come back so a lot of
people are just now figuring out the
devastation of their
housing and animals and their vehicles
and just you know and everything's got
to be rebuilt it has been a challenge
for us to get in here
authorities here say no one from the
public will be allowed into the most
impacted areas where the difficult work
of sifting through the ashes for remains
continues you know the whole Community
didn't burn down there's a lot of folks
that are living in this community and
the people that are living here don't
access to Services there's no power
businesses aren't open but they still
need food water diapers medication
officials say those who survived are
scattered across a dozen shelters
serving more than 4 000 people
the cause of the fire is still under
investigation survivors we've heard from
have pointed to downed power lines like
these behind me faulty fire hydrants and
emergency alarms that sat silent pharah
neither garcha in Maui thank you for
that nithu
and U.S President Joe Biden and first
lady Jill Biden will head to Hawaii next
week to survey the damage in Lahaina the
commander-in-chief is going to touch
down on Monday and we'll meet with First
Responders and survivors and as if you
mentioned strong winds from Hurricane
Dora fanned the flames and there's some
evidence gusts on August 8th were strong
enough to bring down some power lines on
Maui an investigation into the exact
cause of the fire that destroyed Lahaina
is only just beginning but there is
strong video evidence from that day
including the ignition of a fire just
after 6 30 in the morning on the
hillside above Lahaina Mike drolet takes
us through the timeline from that day
and the tough questions that are now
being asked
oh this is live right across the street
from my house
freaking power line just went down could
this be the spark that Lit the Lahaina
Blaze on Tuesday August 8th at 6 37 a.m
Shane true heard electrical pops coming
from the power lines there's a power
line right there and shortly after I
think was just arcing away on the ground
landed right in dry grass so Sparks and
then there was a fire a heads up the
line is live there on the ground right
there by 9 A.M Maui fire reported the
brush fire 100 percent contained it
would be hours before the chaos here it
is now very Gusty winds prior to all
that meteorologists had issued warnings
for two days about the impending high
winds there was a red flag fire warning
at 10 47 p.m the night before Lahaina
the winds caused arcing on power lines
at a bird Conservation Center
Maui's aging power infrastructure
suffered more failures throughout the
night yet Hawaiian Electric doesn't have
a shut off plan like some Utilities in
California because not everyone agrees
they work you want us to turn the power
on he wants to do an after action she's
going to turn the dang power on
okay you want you want notifications or
you want the power shut off
you don't get it both ways so the power
remained on by 1 pm old Power pools were
swaying with the wind and then at 3 30
PM the reportedly contained Lahaina
brush fire reignited you get all this
wind blowing and now you gotta fire it
just that was fuel in this in a matter
of minutes that whole place was just
engulfed
there's no warning for residents the 80
sirens on Maui remain silent mobile
phone alerts were sent but too late or
to phones that didn't have service
lawsuits alleging neglect within the
utility company have already been filed
the victims are still being pulled From
the Ashes yet residents want answers now
primarily could this tragedy have been
averted microwave Global News
a troubling Trend in Canadian real
estate coming up the consequences of a
cool down in housing Construction Plus
snubbed China leaves Canada off a key
list
there is new setback tonight in Canada's
housing crisis housing starts slipped by
10 percent in July when compared with
June according to the Canada mortgage
and housing Corporation and in some of
Canada's biggest cities they dropped
even more and it's becoming increasingly
difficult to afford a home in this
country the income required has
increased in all 10 major cities as
Mackenzie gray reports High interest
rates are piling on the pressure
scenes like this are the number one way
out of the housing crisis but new
construction in Canada has taken a big
hit with a Slowdown in housing starts
right now we're headed in the wrong
direction the Canadian housing and
mortgage Corporation announcing nearly
30 000 fewer homes started Construction
in July compared to the month before a
trend even worse in Canada's most
expensive cities with a 23 drop in
Vancouver and a 29 decline in Toronto
this lack of housing construction is
going to cause both house prices and
rents to go up and we've seen rents
across the country go up 20 percent or
more year over year on new leases the
culprit for constrained construction a
triple whammy of increased land prices
High development fees charged by
governments and a huge run-up in
interest rates those factors also
leading to 22 percent of Builders to
cancel projects that had already started
these costs have just escalated in such
a way that this project no longer shows
the possibility of profit but the dip in
new builds are a drop in the Market
compared to what's required to bring
affordability back to the Canadian
housing market something one of the top
economists at cmhc says hasn't happened
since the 1970s we need three and a half
million additional housing units by 2030
and very roughly that would mean
doubling housing starts like we we need
drastically higher housing starts the
Liberals haven't committed to meeting
the cmhc's affordability goals despite
house prices increasing by 84 percent
since Justin Trudeau became prime
minister in 2015. my focus right now is
making sure that whatever your income
may be if you're working this country
you have a place that you can afford to
pay for I don't think that's too much to
ask despite the Slowdown of new
construction and most Canadian cities
house prices are stagnating and they're
likely to go down Farah as higher
interest rates work their way through
the Canadian economy
Mackenzie gray and Ottawa thank you for
that Mac ABC woman notorious for posing
as a fake nurse is facing another round
of criminal charges 51-year-old Brigitte
claro was charged last week with fraud
over five thousand dollars impersonation
using forged documents and assault for
alleged offenses committed at a private
clinic in the Greater Victoria area in
2020. claro has never had a valid
nursing license or completed nursing
school yet she assisted with surgeries
and care for more than 1100 women at BC
Women's Hospital during 2020 and 2021.
Claro's criminal record spans four
provinces and two U.S states over three
decades
now to a surfing Adventure in Indonesia
that went very wrong four Australian
Surfers in their three Indonesian guides
were boating out to an island surfing
spot aboard a small wooden speed boat
when they hit bad weather 36 hours after
they disappeared search teams finally
found the four Surfers and two of their
guides bobbing on their surfboards
massive thanks to our friends here on
the island they did such an amazing job
statistically to pull through and just
like not stop searching the whole time
and you know there were some moments out
there where we're all quite nervous
it's not all good news Indonesian search
crews are still looking for one of the
crew members who's still missing for
decades Surfers have been taking risky
trips to hard to reach places across
Indonesia looking for that perfect wave
Air Assault ahead Russia's Relentless
attacks on Ukrainian grain silos
[Music]
Russian drones pounded Ukrainian grain
silos in the South again overnight the
airstrikes targeted facilities at one of
the key Danube River ports collapsing
walls and scattering grain Ukraine's
Danube ports had accounted for about a
quarter of grain exports before Russia
pulled out of a major deal last month it
provided safe passage for the export of
Ukrainian grain through the Black Sea
today a loaded shipping container set
sail through the Black Sea after being
stuck at the Port of Odessa since Russia
launched its full-scale War it traveled
through a temporary Corridor made by
Ukraine for merchant shipping
has left Canada off its list if approved
destinations for Group Travel Tours can
be booked in more than 70 countries but
not Canada China says it's related to
what is called it calls Canada's hyped
up allegations of foreign interference
and it also blames a rise in rampant
anti-asian attacks
what's on your mind next how artificial
intelligence could one day answer that
question
[Music]
and then there were two England will
meet Spain in the Women's World Cup
final after putting a pin in the party
down under defeating host nation
Australia and it was a heartbreaking end
for the Australian team known as the
matildas losing 3-1 to England but it
was Australia's samker stealing the show
scoring what will likely be the goal of
the tournament firing a long-range
rocket it's the first time England has
ever made it to the Women's World Cup
final
artificial intelligence can compose a
song it can write an essay and now
researchers in Singapore are working on
mind reading literally the scientists
are using MRI brain scans and AI to see
if they can figure out what someone is
looking at there are of course ethical
considerations but this could one day
also help people who are non-verbal to
communicate Redmond Shannon explains how
it all works
have you ever worried that someone knows
exactly what you're thinking
well Lee has come to the National
University of Singapore to see if that's
really possible
he and other participants in this study
spend hours inside a noisy MRI machine a
very important
while inside they are shown thousands of
images each for nine seconds and their
brain is scanned each time using all
those scans they build an artificial
intelligence model for the participant
on their next visit to the machine they
will stare at new images and researchers
will try to replicate the pictures using
the AI model and stable diffusion a
public AI image generator but instead of
words scientists input brain scan data
this translator will translate your
brand activities into a special language
that a stable diffusion can understand
and then it will generate
the images you are seeing at that point
these are some of the images
participants looked at and these are
what the AI model carved up some
reproductions more accurate than others
it's just simple images for now and each
person's brain needs a different model
but scientists hope the research could
one day help disabled or non-verbal
people maybe we can help him to like
control their
um their robots and um their their phone
like I'll communicate with communicate
with others
reading someone's mind is fraught with
ethical concerns could brain scan
patients have their thoughts tracked or
could the MRI be used as a lie detector
researchers say legislation is needed
before the technology matures this is
going to be very very difficult
right so yeah it's going to take us at
least another five to ten years I think
of course no one will accidentally
stroll through an MRI machine so for now
at least our thoughts are ours alone
radman Shannon Global News London
certainly a good thing and that's global
national for this Wednesday night I'm
Farah Nasser on the whole crew and I
thank you so much for spending part of
your evening with us tonight's your
Canada is North Rustico Prince Edward
Island we love senior Canada so please
keep emailing us your photos to viewers
at globalnational.com until we're
together tomorrow take care of
yourselves and take care of each other
good night
foreign
[Music]